khloe kardashian is speaking out
after taking heat for trying to have a
pic in a bikini
taken off social media isn't that crazy
the reality star went live on instagram
wednesday
showing off her toned physique as ariana
grande's pov
played in the background
[Music]
[Applause]
then coco shared another video wearing
nothing but nude underwear
alongside a lengthy message about
feeling judged for how she looks
the note starts off quote hey guys this
is me
and my body unretouched and unfiltered
the video is a response to people who
claim
she has digitally altered bikini snaps
to appear
thinner especially after a photo was
recently posted that chloe didn't like
the 36 year old reportedly worked hard
to have the pick removed
and several fans who reposted the snap
claimed their accounts were frozen and
their posts were deleted according to a
statement obtained by page six
tracy romulus the chief marketing
officer for kkw brands
said in a statement that the photo was
taken during a private family gathering
and posted to social media without
permission by mistake
by an assistant quote chloe looks
beautiful but it is within the right of
the copyright owner to not want an
image not intended to be published taken
down
and chloe echoed all that on instagram
saying that while the pick is beautiful
quote as someone who has struggled with
body image her whole life
when someone takes a photo of you that
isn't flattering in bad lighting or
doesn't capture your body the way it is
after working so hard to get it to this
point and then
shares it to the world you should have
every right to ask for it to not be
shared she went on to say that the quote
pressure constant ridicule and judgment
she's faced her whole life to meet other
standards of how she should look
has quote been too much to bear the
revenge body star shared some examples
of the hateful things she's read about
herself on social media
and in the tabloids before explaining
that she's not asking for sympathy
but rather to be quote acknowledged for
being human
coco concluded her post writing quote i
have realized that we cannot continue to
live life
trying to fit into the perfect mold of
what others have set for us
just do you and make sure your heart is
happy
and that's exactly what chloe told et
back in 2019
beauty starts from the inside i really
think i'm in a good place but i think
working on your personal growth
internally is something that will be a
forever
mission and i always want to evolve and
grow and mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
people but chloe's response to the
haters
should come as no surprise to fans of
keeping up with the kardashians
on a recent episode of the family's hit
reality show chloe opened up about being
picked apart in the public eye
my soul it's like at a breaking point
from how much i could handle
in regards to the public thinking
they're allowed to talk about my weight
my face my personal life just like
actually i
don't want to hear this anymore i've
always been incredibly vulnerable
and so open with the show with my life
i've never
thought twice about it but i just don't
think i have it in me anymore
and it's not healthy from my spirit as
for coco's post
she got a whole lot of support and
praise from her loved ones
kendall jenner hit the insta live with a
yes and
body while andy cohen sent a whole bunch
of fire emojis
and kim kardashian who was there to
cheer chloe on during her live stream
swooped into the comments writing i love
you chloe
you